[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and uhoh spaghettio Loki
season 2 has just thrown us a big
curveball if you're still wondering what
just happened then this is the video for
you throughout it we're going to be
going over the final few scenes and
discussing how Victor timely's untimely
death could still pave the way for he
who remains to emerge heavy spoilers
that will not we've spoiled it already
and but the first thing I want to talk
about is the pruning of raona Ren Slayer
this video will contain from the trailer
that haven't been in the series yet
though so be warned and get yourself
pruned if you don't want to get rued now
the first thing I want to talk about is
a short and sweet explanation for what's
happened with ravona Rens Slayer in the
entry she gets pruned by X5 which is
sort of a reversal of season 1 episode 4
during that Mobius was pruned by hunted
E90 and this came under the orders of
raona renser in season 2 episode 4 we
see both D90 and raona getting pruned
which flips the script in an ironic way
now looking at the trailer we actually
have some shots of raona in the void
which is where she's clearly coming face
to face with elith that's still down
there and I think we'll watch your
escape from the void and see she goes on
a similar journey to Sylvia and Loki I'm
guessing that D90 will get killed by
elith as a demonstration of how
dangerous it is but he may also work
alongside raona to help bust her out
either way the void is the perfect place
for some Varan cameos and I'd love to
see the lowy variants we met last time
returning for this series 2 now as for
Victor Timely him getting spaghettified
it to be fair it probably had you like I
mean how can he be the
one if he's dead however however however
his death actually makes sense if you're
able to grasp the timely wely wibbly
wobbly stuff going on with the show now
in episode 3 we watch the bootstrap
Paradox playing out in full effect with
he who remains instructing raona to
leave Victor timely the TVA manual this
had to be done by her as misiz Minit
isn't actually able to physically
interact with objects and thus someone
like raona was needed to act as a
messenger now interestingly you might
notice that episode 3 starts off in the
sacred timeline but when Loki and Mobius
jump to the Future this then becomes a
branched one so he who remains clearly
carried this out for a specific reason
and this shows that his own creation is
linked by the fact that he himself has
to be created through a branch in
reality I think Ryan AR I think Bloody
Ryan AR came up with this first but
looking at it it makes a lot of sense
shut the up raner Victor timley is on
the sacred timeline because this is the
one that sets up the events that will
eventually lead to the loom exploding
creating a far more expensive Multiverse
the loom explodes because it can't
handle all the timelines and now the
Multiverse is truly opened up with being
an infinite number of realities created
the loom had just been keeping things to
a certain number but it overloading in
the show opens up everything I believe
that it's in one of these realities that
he who remains is born and this and
allows him to continue on the buck being
dropped off in the sacred timeline takes
it to timely who then puts things in
effect that lead to the loom being
destroyed destroyed had he given it to
another then they might end up having
some technology that could fix the loom
and therefore he needs to find a version
of himself that's completely useless
that's definitely the case with timely
as well as he's a Conan who though able
to make and design things doesn't seem
as Adept as the other kangs that we've
encountered except for the one who got
beat by ants and the reason that the
timeline's considered the sacred one is
because this is the one that Victor Tim
on he who remains knows that he's
crucial to his own creation and thus
he's pruned the other realities and just
left this one that's the reason why it's
classed as the sacred timeline because
Victor timely goes on to create he who
remains he who remains prunes to
timelines and takes things under control
and then sends the book back to timely
so the cycle can continue it's the
perfect bootstrap Paradox that keeps
everything in place and thus he who
remains can he who remains at the top I
think the release schedule it's kind of
mess things up with the way these
stories are being told technically I
think this series is happening before
the event of quantum Mania as we pick up
immediately after the events of the
first season that happened after the
segue in endgame and then went off into
its own thing thus when the loom blows
up several of the ks can Branch off
explaining why there's so many in the
Coliseum that might be me just grasping
at things but looking at how things have
released I'd imagine that's how it's all
playing out when it comes to stacking my
Blu-rays in chronological order I must
insist I'm going to stick these two
seasons after endgame and then Quantum
Mania further on either way I think he
who remains needed the loom to be
destroyed which then helps to open up
the other realities now what I then
think happens is that the tva's
destroyed and everyone on it sent back
to where they were in the timeline this
is why when we watch the trailers we can
see loky time slipping and he pops up in
front of a jet ski shop I believe that
this is where Mobius will be at and
we'll see his real life on the timeline
now these people need to be put back
here so he who remains can recruit them
as at some point everything needs to be
reset now this is a similar thing to
what happened with Miss minutes 2 as we
know she was an AI that he who remains
reprogrammed and this was so she could
work at his side The Miz minute we
follows out lives he who remains and
thus there needs to be a point in which
he recruits the initial version it can't
just be too floating around and there at
some point she needed to be wiped out
this is what we saw happening during
episode 4 and I believe the TVA agents
needed to go through this too we can't
have a TVA intact when he remains
arrives cuz then he'll be behind where
these people are chronologically thus
the reset was inevitable and it needed
to wipe the Sligh clean so everything
can start up again having these key
figures put back in place will allow
them to then start the journey and this
will in turn lead to the TVA so this big
thing at the end it actually makes a lot
of sense and it could also send things
in a direction that we're already aware
of as we know from Quantum Mania there
was an exile who turned against the
council and was then cast out this is
the one who would goone on to become
Kang and Quantum Mania who who I also
think is actually he who remains though
he was seemingly killed at the end of
the film I think he just went into
another part of either the Multiverse or
Quantum realm itself now him instructing
raona to do something that eventually
led to Victor's death could also show
his plans playing out perfectly if he is
the Exile then he's obviously being cast
out and has likely realized what needs
to be done he who remains touched upon
the multiversal war that was caused by
his variants and this is why the TVA was
set up he who remains was all at that
was because he was All That Remains and
this came after taking out all his other
variants this was likely done through
the war with him killing the entirity of
the rest of the council make no mistake
this is a war between him and the others
and thus him taking out Victor's one L
hang that he has to worry about if this
does take place after Quantum Mania then
it makes sense why he was sent there too
sending someone from another reality
into where a k doesn't exist may help to
mitigate this effect as We Know
incursions are a big thing as well and
they have the potential to destroy Two
Earths sending someone from another
reality into one where a Kang doesn't
exist this might actually help to
mitigate this effect we're still unsure
exactly how incursions work in the MCU
though they do operate differently from
the comics from what's been said so far
they tend to be caused by someone from
one world who then goes into another and
then the two worlds are pulled into each
other this is so they can syn up and
doing this on a Quantum level may stop
the effect hence why the Exile was sent
there now Quant to Mania two takes place
on the sacred timeline and thus Kang
would be aware of this reality he may
also know that this is where timely was
and there's one to remain on that one
with it being his Central home as we
said this is the one where Victor timely
was and giving him the buck then created
the branch this did show that Victor
wasn't always meant to get it but I
still think he may have become an
inventor due to what we see him doing as
a child on top of this I also believe
that Loki will be the one who takes over
the position of he who remains while the
war is going on someone needs to lead
whilst that's happening and th I think
ly will end up in this spot eventually
with the stuff going on with Mages as
well they may even make him the villain
of Secret Wars instead of it being K
Kang was never the bad guy for that
story in the comics and both its
iterations centered around Dr Doom the
way the MCU is heading it seems like
it's going to be whoever's in the hot
seat and ly also has the president for
this in the comics during the agent of
Asgard Arc we discovered an older
version of ly was ruling over everything
and controlling things from the Shadows
I'd love it if it was revealed that the
Richard E Grand version or something was
the one that was in the far future even
Beyond where he who remains was
controlling this entire Loop and this
was all done so L he could put himself
on top it would make he who remains a
porn in that plan too and also explain
how he had the script that outlined what
Loki and Sylvia were going to say I
think there's still a lot of ways they
can take things and even though this is
all part of a loop it's still packed
with a lot of surprises I felt like I
had this entire thing SU out especially
when Loki pruned himself but clearly
there's way more going on with it I
still think that he remains is creating
his own origin but we are going to see
how this whole thing plays out obviously
though let me know your comments below
did I make a lick of sense I'm sure well
I'm hoping there's some stuff in there
that at least makes sense but yeah if
you have any other theories drop them
below it's all time travel all timey Wy
wibbly wobbly stuff and yeah I'd love to
hear your thought on it cuz there's so
many things to discuss please drop a
like on the video as well and if you
want to support the channel as a member
of the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us at you want to
get some heavy spoilers merch we've also
got a t-shirt line located below the
video that will let you pick up tops
like our Loki one Theory time one house
of dragon stuff SOA teas and more we
drop new designs on there all the time
too just like our classic breakdown
versus one so definitely head over there
right after this without the way huge
thank you for sing through the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care
peace